stafford avenue district council is
currently consulting on a site
allocations plan
this video focuses on two specific site
proposals that are closely related to
the town of stratford-upon-avon
both of which are for business uses it
is important to bear in mind that both
sides are already allocated in the core
strategy adopted in july 2016
so the principle of their development is
already established
proposal sua2 is south of ulster road
the site comprises 23 hectares of land
south of the a46 ulster road
immediately to the west of wildsmore
roundabout
the two main purposes behind the site
being allocated are
one to provide an opportunity for
companies to move to the town
in order to bolster the local economy
and provide new jobs
and two to provide scope for businesses
in the canal quarter regeneration zone
to relocate and allow that area to be
redeveloped
however circumstances have changed in
recent years and the district council
believes that a more flexible approach
is justified
regarding the types of business uses
that are appropriate on the site
in particular provision is now made for
a car dealership and a bulky goods
retail store
as well as for offices and industrial
uses
what is retained is the scope for
businesses to relocate from the canal
quarter regeneration zone
specific controls will be applied to
ensure that such businesses have the
opportunity to do so for a period of
time
once the site starts to be developed
it should be noted that outline paneling
permission was granted in december 2019
for a mixed-use business park
associated with this is a full planning
permission for a new roundabout access
from the a46 then we've got proposal
sua4
atherston airfield this site is part of
a former airfield located on the a3
a4 300 ships in road about two
kilometers from the southern edge of the
town
an area of 10 hectares is identified for
employment uses
the original proposal sought to restrict
these uses to businesses relocating from
the canal quarter
again however it is apparent to the
district council that a more flexible
approach is required in order to
implement the site
giving the infrastructure costs involved
for this reason it is proposed that the
relocation of businesses
from elsewhere in the district including
those already based on other parts of
the oscar to state should be supported
in addition this may be extended to
businesses relocating from outside the
district
if it can be justified in order to
facilitate the delivery of the canal
quarter
a detailed transport assessment will be
required to establish the impact of
additional traffic on the local road
network
the provision of extensive landscaping
around the edge of the site to reduce
visual impact on the surrounding area
will be expected
i hope this has helped explain these two
sites and remember you can find out more
about the site allocations plan and
submit any comments you have
by visiting our website at
www.stratford.gov dot uk forward slash
sappo